all right let's continue our tour of the
insanity that was the turning point usa
uh student event in tampa florida they
really get the students fired up this is
a full-on indoctrination type event this
is the type of thing you would imagine
is taking place uh done by the
government of north korea for example
and the we we've actually seen and
talked about such events in north korea
one of the we've already looked at what
donald trump said one of the other
speakers was donald trump jr now we've
seen a lot of video of donald trump jr
i have never seen him this wired
and of course the speculation is that he
is on some kind of upper
there are different opinions as to what
upper that is
uh i will sort of stop my analysis there
but um making very very little sense
really hopped up sped up and and this
video is not sped up importantly
like i've never seen it like she can do
like a half an hour and like there's
like three words
no it's
it's like
i don't know whether to be like upset or
impressed
you know
like the crazy crap that hillary was
saying last week she was like yeah
that's perfect here
kamala is your speech writer
camilla like that's next
and the only thing scarier again than
perhaps joe biden would be come up yeah
so this is his anti-kamala rant don jr
then moving on to claiming covet
variants are invented conspiracy
theories and all sorts of other stuff
that should should get you put in a
loony bin quite frankly and i know that
that's not a politically correct term it
should make us question one's sanity but
the crowd loves it the crowd cheers this
is a crowd where this stuff is rewarded
remember folks
the difference between a conspiracy
theory and the truth
it used to be about six months right
was there anything all the things we've
been talking about has there been one
that we were wrong about
in the end meaning we were told we were
wrong we were canceled if you were a
doctor and you questioned clown fauci uh
you know you were thrown out of the
medical profession
any one of those things
ah turns out they were right huh it
doesn't matter we got what we wanted
let's move on
the difference is now it's like six
minutes
right between
what your label conspiracy theory turns
out to be the truth they can't hide it
anymore because it's compounding so
badly
it just doesn't stop
and we're going to see this more right
we're either going to have a midterm
variant obviously right right
so they can implement whatever they need
to do fraudulent voting and whatever it
may be
or you're seeing
you guys are seeing it
you know it's coming
the monkey pox pandemic folks
this is another one which again they the
they're they're taking both sides of the
monkey pox stuff
where on the one hand they're starting
to say
covet clearly was some kind of concocted
psyop because now we've got monkey pox
and nobody's saying we gotta shut down
because of monkey pox that proves
something about covet was fake it's like
well though cove it's a respiratory
virus it spreads extraordinarily easily
monkey pox is spreading through physical
contact sexual contact skin to skin
so
the transmission is completely different
so why would the reaction be the same
but at the same time they're starting to
say
monkey pox is being set up to do the
same thing that they did they did with
covid so they'll have it both ways on
all of these things uh one other kind of
funny moment was now don jr is rewriting
history about when trump had to be
helped down that ramp by uh by a general
remember when trump
walked down a ramp it was like raining
and slippery so we held onto the
banister and it was like he's in the
later stages of dementia and alzheimer's
combined
he is literally about to drop dead oh my
god 25th amendment now it was actually
uh not raining that day it was sunny and
i went back just because i was like am i
misremembering the day that trump walked
down the ramp it was a beautiful sunny
day at the time that donald trump walked
down with his hand held by the general
doesn't change anything one way or the
other not a big deal but they're just
straight up rewriting history at this
point and the crowd loves it now last
thing donald trump also has evidence
that he is being suppressed and that the
right is being suppressed which is his
posts don't get as many likes as they
used to
have you ever noticed it only goes one
way
yeah like you know
i'm getting like 10 000 likes a post
from like 300 000 like couple months ago
because they don't like me right now
right if you're effective they're gonna
suppress you we are working that much
harder
yeah so that's the new proof that of
course there is some
subterfuge at play don jr is getting
fewer likes so the crowd loves it don jr
is hopped up as i've ever seen him and
the hits just came coming next is lauren
bober my audience knows i read i read a
ton of books i read nonfiction i read
fiction at night i'm always trying to
consume information and the truth is i
don't have the time to read every
non-fiction book that i would like to
read one thing i do not have time to add
to what i'm reading in paper form
is more history but i want to know about
history and that's where our sponsor
blinkist comes in blinkist doesn't
replace reading books cover to cover the
way i love to do but for example with
everything going on right now with roe v
wade i wanted more of a detailed history
of roe v wade in the united states so on
blinkist i was able to get a 15-minute
condensed audiobook of the mary ziegler
book abortion and the law in america roe
v wade to the present and in 15 minutes
i get a great overview blinkist also has
slide presentations that will take you
about 15 minutes to go through so it's
not to replace reading it's in addition
to for me you get the key takeaways from
blinkist from the books i would
certainly otherwise miss out on you can
try blinkist for free for seven days and
get a 25 percent discount off of a
subscription at blinkist.com pacman the
link is down below